I really want to start by saying uh the
zone of interest is it's kind of good
um in fact thank you when I say kind of
good I mean it's fantastic
um so I want to jump right on and I have
so many questions for you but what was
it like actually reading the script for
this for the first time because it's
because it's not there's so much that
happens off camera and the use of sound
and I'm just curious whether it's like
reading the script for the first time
and seeing what Jonathan was going for
um reading the script for the first time
was amazing it was a great script
um and in the script
um all the noises you hear is written
down in in the script so not exactly
everything but it's it was you have a
vision if you read the script you have a
vision for for what John wants to do and
for me the starting
um coming into this project was um funny
because I had to do is healthy to
describe myself and
um and why I'm becoming an actor without
knowing the script without knowing the
potential role only knowing it's a
project it's a new project of Jonathan
Glazer and I grew up with Jonathan's
work without knowing that the director's
name is Jonathan Glazer but I know the
music videos some of the commercials he
did and then I I did this um selfie and
then I met John for the first time
in a pub in London together with his
longtime friend Jim Wilson and um and
then he shares with me his vision his
thoughts he shares with me what could be
the potential role in it and photos in
his investigation and and then I read
the script for the first time and I was
really impressed because
um it was it's it reminds me of the
script when I read the white ribbon um I
played the school teacher white ribbon
and when I read the script from the
white ribbon there were no questions and
here too but he changed the script
um we worked because of the covert
um situation we have we had to postpone
the whole project for one year and um
and then we had a lot of conversations
about the script
um that knowing okay Sandra and me
will be this couple and then what could
be a good situation what what is not a
good situation then we changed the
script or he changed with us the script
can I ask do you think that kovid made
the project even better I think so for
me personally uh because I had to do I
had to learn horseback riding because it
was important for the party and I had
one year more and that was great and to
do to have this preparation and to know
this will be a very intense shooting
because the set the garden it's the set
design is it's amazing from Chris Audi
and the shooting with 10 cameras
simultaneously and so on and and to
prepare for this character for this
project
for me it was even better than it was
postponed for one year one of the things
that you mentioned just now about the
cameras and I wanted to get specific
about that it was a very unusual way
that you shot the film can you let
people know about that unusual way and
what was it like as an actor when you're
in a set but there's nobody really
around it's just the actors that was a
luxury situation without technical
interruptions or something because I
hate this in the normal shooting process
because you are in a in a moment in a
feeling and then you have to interrupt
and stop this and then come back because
here we had the luxury situation we had
a lot of time and the cameras were
hidden in the house in the garden and it
was allowed to play in the house at the
same time in the garden sometimes we
shot scenes simultaneously I was in a
room with the common dance
um Sandra was in a room with her friends
and I hear the voice of the other scene
and we do that was crazy and it's it's
was
it was great and it was helpful to find
the naturality for the situations and
for our characters too and even outside
we had the writing scene with my son it
was a great area I think I don't know
two kilometers and there were 10 cameras
hidden and we had from trapped to Gallup
and it was amazing it feels real in this
moment we
it was not acting so that was really
helpful it's uh it I'm fascinated how so
many different directors work in
different ways and yet
um and they all work there's no right
method to making a movie absolutely and
I think here John it was important for
John the observing thing we observed the
family we looking through the window to
the family and this system helped was
really helpful for this because we don't
see
um the characters in uh
Big Shot we don't follow them we observe
them and that was great because we don't
know
what angle will be the final angle or
something and that was great it was
I don't care it's that was really really
great to to know
I'm not an actor who's who's looking
into the uh monitor after a shoot and oh
I have to look sexy or something that's
not important for me
um this decisions yeah this is the
director's decision and here it was
great for us
um we don't know which angle and yeah it
was I think it was a luxury and helpful
situation for us I definitely want to
talk about what it was like for you
watching the film for the first time
because he does things in the in the
final version which I don't know if it
was in the script the way that it starts
is an unusual beginning there are other
unusual things and his exceptional use
of sound and what's off screen and using
your the audience's imagination uh is a
very powerful tool in this film for me
it was
um I was really surprised when I saw the
movie for the first time
and I was really thrilled and impressed
uh at the same time and it was
uncomfortable for me to watch too
um
and we haven't hear the noises or the
sounds we haven't seen the camp we we we
shoot the first part of the movie The
Summer part very close to the original
camp and very close to to the original
House his house
but all these I think there's a second
movie if you close your eyes you you see
a different movie and this is really
amazing and I was really impressed about
that and really overwhelmed that it
works so because if you're shooting a
movie with this idea with this vision
you don't know if it's if it works or
but to realize it works that was really
great and Sandra me uh we we were in a
little small Cinema in Leipzig her
hometown
and with her doc we wear together the
doc is the dog in the movie it was a
premiere for the doc to see
um the movie for the first time and
especially you you said the beginning or
the end in in the script the beginning
or the end we're different than what we
see in the movie and I think after the
cleaning woman
come back to root of us and he getting
down the stairs it's it's a genius cut I
will I would say and Sandra and me we
said wow when we saw the movie for the
first time and we this moment especially
and we felt okay this is a really unique
um
movie yeah for sure but I definitely
have to talk to you about working with
Sandra because she is so fantastic in
the movie and is so Disturbed you know
such an uh evil person
um what was it like actually
collaborating with her because uh she's
having a very good year also she has she
has a great she has a great year and I'm
so happy for her and I hope give her all
the awards uh I mean she's fantastic in
both films both films what what a year
and she she's an incredible and
inspiring uh actress for me and a
incredible human being too and we work
together for the first time years ago in
Jessica hausner's movie amofu and I
played Heinrich from Christ and she was
my cousin and we had two very very funny
scenes
and
we we've had for the first time there's
a connection between us and we're
becoming friends and it was very helpful
for this specialty movie and to making
this movie and I think the key moments
for me were the conversations with her
and with John uh we had a lot of
conversations and that was really
helpful to create the characters and and
to know yes they do evil things but they
are normal human beings and I think this
is the most important thing if you watch
the movie you realize okay human beings
do incredible horrible things
to other human beings and I think this
is for me the main message and yeah so
one of the things though is that uh
every actor I speak to like making a
movie is like a marathon so what was it
like inhabiting this character and
playing this for a period of time
um for you it was really intense I had
this beautiful haircut for two years
and to Christmas my family was really
thankful
um now for me it was really intense
because
um
there are things in my subconscious I
have to deal with it and sometimes I had
the feeling
it's it's an easy situation it's not
difficult to do this now to have a
birthday party or have a dinner with a
family or something but making this
movie creating this character with this
historical context the responsibility
towards the victims all these things and
now watching this movie and be
overwhelmed and
and there's a lot of things it was a
really intense sometimes difficult
Journey for me but I'm really grateful
and really proud to be a part of this
Masterpiece oh no the film is fantastic
I'm just a daughter time with you so I
want to ask you one question but I want
to look at the camera and say this is a
spoiler so stop watching now if you have
not seen the movie because I'm asking
something about specifically about the
film do not watch this part unless you
have seen the movie Rudolph has his
death
no I am curious though uh did Jonathan
tell you
um when he is throwing up why or did you
decide for yourself why is it because
you can interpret it a few different
ways and I'm just curious your take on
it for me personally we talked a lot
about this and I was really afraid to do
the scene because
um I hate bro and then I think the last
time I was throwing it's 20 years or 25
years ago and I realized okay John likes
method acting and to find the reality
and I was really afraid of that and we
had a lot of conversations and there is
an inspiration for the scene
for every scene in
um he had some notes and and memories of
of people who worked in the his house
for me this scene is a battle the body
against the mind
but he don't realize his guilt he he he
he he's thinking okay I wash my hands
but the blood stays at his hands and I
think you see a battle
but he don't realize what's going on and
this is my interpretation but I hope
that the people have different
interpretations because
and even
um if you watch the end of the movie and
to see this master cut
going into the future coming back in the
past and what's going on what's what's
his thoughts
we don't know it but that's what I mean
like it one of the things I really loved
about it is that uh it's open to the
audience to decide what is Jonathan
doing in this scene because you can play
it like that the characters having what
you just said you can play it like is he
getting a glimpse of the future and
reacting to it like there's I don't
think so that he realized that and even
if you hear his original voice in the
Nuremberg Trial you can hear it at
YouTube
um it's a high voice and you it's a
voice not of a perpetrator it's a voice
of a bureaucrat and and a prisoner and
he talks
every detail he's he tell every detail
to in in in this trial but he never said
it's my guilt he said I have to do it it
was my work so and this is horrible
disturbing
um uh I really want to say seriously
congrats on your amazing work in this
film thank you for being part of such an
incredible movie
um and thank you for stopping by Tiff
and I wish you nothing but the best
thank you so much thank you